c'est patrick kanner d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et des autres invités
politiques ce matin sénateur du nord
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
directeur adjoint de la campagne dany
d'algues on est ensemble pendant 25
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale dont jours stéphane bern et
bonjour bonjour je suis 2e ouest france
et on commence évidemment d'en parler à
l'instant avec le sénateur par cette
information d'hier soir on a appris la
mort d' yvan colonna condamné pour
l'assassinât du préfet erignac décédé
des suites de sa très violente agression
en prison est ce que vous craignez une
reprise des violences sur l'île de
beauté pour l'instant les choses sont
calmes et je pense que y compris le
sénateur par eddy a raison de dire qu'il
faut garder ce calme garder le respect
pour yvan colonna qui est décédé qui est
qui payé sa dette à la nation et qui a
été assassinée disons le clairement dans
un lieu public un lieu de privation de
liberté mais un lieu qui devait être
sous l'autorité publique
il faudra que l'état s'explique
et il est vrai j'entendais l'interview
précédente que le silence de monsieur
dupont moretti devient assourdissant
dans ce dans ce dossier quelles que
soient les éventuels le conflit
d'intérêt historique qui pouvait il y
avoir donc moi je vois je souhaite que
les choses soient clarifiées dans l'est
dans les meilleurs délais
il y a eu une faute de l'administration
pénitentiaire il faut que donc alors on
explique le pourquoi le comment de cette
faute que les que les sanctions tombent
et puis pour la corse naturellement moi
j'invite chacun à garder son calme mais
je suis inquiet on a vu les séquences
précédente
aujourd'hui c'est le temps du deuil il
faut le respecter notamment pour la
famille pour les amis pour les proches
de monsieur colonna
après
je le train je le crains je ne souhaite
pas naturellement
il est politique doivent avoir le même
message qu'ils soient des deux sur de
corse en tant que tel j'ai entendu le
message du président simeoni des
messages d'apaisement de calme il faut
l'écouter il faut que les forces de
l'ordre soient aussi à la hauteur de
leurs responsabilités en la matière il y
aura des provocations probablement donc
essayons de sortir par le haut et
d'avoir une solution politique comme
celle qui est avancé même si
permettez-moi de regretter quand même
que on parle déjà d'autonomie il faudra
voir dire ce qu'on met derrière le mot
avant même de faire le bilan de
l'évolution statutaire de la corse
n'aurait pas
dit il qu'il le met en perspective mais
pas comme étant la solution c'est
vraiment là on y va très très fort et
très vite l'accord cela que la
collectivité de corse a été
modifié en termes de statut je rappelle
qu'il ya eu la loi de notre en 2015
statut en 2018 on est quatre ans plus
tard on ne fait même pas encore le bilan
de ce qui s'est passé le plus le moins
puis on balance ça comme ça donc on
répond à la marge un problème de
violence dans une prison totalement
inacceptable sans vraiment avoir fait le
travail de fond et ça c'est pour moi de
la navigation à vue et sur un sujet
aussi sensible que celui de la corse il
faut être très prudent ce travail là il
peut être fait par une commission d'
enquête sur la surveillance dans les
prisons en probablement probablement
alors c'est vrai
oui je la soie être je pense même que le
qu'il pourrait on pas imaginer ce qu au
sénat à l'assemblée que la commission
des lois s'érige en commission une
enquête pour faire ce travail de fond il
ya une faute bien une faute via un homme
est mort aujourd'hui quel que soit son
passé il payé sa dette à la société et
donc
le décès de monsieur colonna voilà crée
une nouvelle situation donc permettez
moi que de l'évoquer j'aurai un groupe
socialiste tout à l'heure en visio donc
ce sera une des questions qui sera posée
raison de se rendre sur l'île à ce
moment là finalement ça cautionne pas ça
ne justifie pas la violence
non le rôle du mythe de l'intérieur
c'est d'être au front en permettez moi
l'expression quand les choses sont
compliquées quand elles vont mal
mais sage femme qu'est ce qu'un problème
difficile qui a été
compliquée pour tous les gouvernements
quels qu'ils soient il y à des
événements de violence sur un territoire
national que le ministre l'intérieur
viennent pour s'expliquer avec le préfet
les forces de l'ordre voire et les
représentants politiques de l'accorte me
semble tout à fait normal donc dans une
république le ministre ne va pas fuir
ses responsabilités et monsieur norman a
été sur place dont acte
le président ukrainien s'exprimera
demain devant les parlementaires
français au cours d'un discours en
visioconférence
est-ce que vous pensez que quel est le
cas les luttes pour vous et quelle est
l'utilité de ce type d'intervention tout
d'abord la parole permet de faire passer
le message par définition et le présent
et là ce qui est est un grand
communicant chacun
la vue il était un communiqué en avant
ses fonctions de président il l'est
aujourd'hui dans un drame absolu et moi
je suis très admiratif de la
multiplication des interventions et vous
remarquerez dans des lieux à chaque fois
différent pour des raisons de sécurité
personnelle donc cet homme est menacée
de mort elles sont indispensables ces
interventions pour maintenir elle nous
interpelle elle nous interpelle elle met
parfois être dans une forme de mauvaise
conscience vis-à-vis du peuple ukrainien
août et il est clair que nous devons pas
rentrer en guerre nous ne rentrons pas
en guerre directe avec
les russes je vois bien parfois
l'impatience et y compris de mes
concitoyens ici de nos concitoyens dix
ans mais peut pas laisser faire ça
qu'est-ce qu'on peut la race de plus
aujourd'hui raisonnablement aujourd'hui
raisonnablement
la livraison d'armes au peuple ukrainien
quittant résistance et la bonne solution
l'aide humanitaire l'accueil des
réfugiés on annonce presque 10 millions
de réfugiés déjà le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés à lens 10 millions 100
mille en france potentiellement 3
millions 5 3 millions 6 dans les pays
limitrophes de l'ukraine donc il ya une
mobilisation politique une mobilisation
militaire au travers de la livraison
d'armes ou mobilisation humanitaire
aussi moyenne autour de l'accueil de
réfugiés pardon et citoyenne aussi
autour de citoyenne une mobilisation
extraordinaire des gens qui ouvrent
leurs portes tout simplement le
c'est potentiellement ce sera
probablement beaucoup plus en tout cas
moi je déconseille au gouvernement de
dire cent mille ans n'arrête personne ne
peut savoir ce qu'il sera et j'ai signé
l'appel de montpellier 2-1 hidalgo qui a
été lancé le 2 mars donc dans cette
ville de montpellier 700 élus ont déjà
répondu pour mettre à disposition des
locaux mettre à disposition des moyens
financiers des moyens matériels il y à
une solidarité assez exceptionnel dans
notre pays et partout en europe
simplement et bien les bombes continuent
à tomber vous avez vu encore cette
dernière image d'un centre commercial
qui a fait plusieurs morts qui a été
explosée par un missile manifestement
extrêmement puissant donc il y à des
équilibres dans les forces en présence
mais la résistance ukrainienne se base
sur un une logique qui est juste
finalement c'est nous sommes un pays
souverain et nous résisterons vous avez
dit monsieur
vraiment vraiment c'est un homme
exceptionnel cet humoriste qui devient
chef de l'état et qui aujourd'hui
finalement devient le symbole de la
liberté d'un peuple et au travers de sa
liberté d'un peuple si la liberté de
l'europe qui est en cause et donc
poutine devra rendre des comptes je
vraiment jeu
lesdits mouvements russe on annonce
dignement russe dans les journaux
officiels russes 1 aujourd'hui c'est une
chose terrible parce qu'il l'a il saigne
le peuple ukrainien mais il saigne aussi
son peuple d'un dictateur sanguinaire
est ce qu'un embargo total sur le gaz et
le pétrole serait un moyen d'aller plus
loin et est ce que l'europe on a les
moyens est ce qu'on est où est ce qu'on
peut se passer du gaz et du pétrole je
connais la rhétorique qui consiste à
dire mais on a besoin de ce pétrole on a
besoin de ce gaz ça nous voisins
beaucoup plus les allemands julien mais
depuis le 24 février je crois que c'est
plus de 25 milliards d'euros que nous
avons acheté de bien de ce type qu'on
peut de charbon hausse et on parle de
500 millions d'euros par jour ces gens
que c'est et lens et avec cet argent là
bas ils financent sa guerre un très très
concrètement donc fermer les robinets ça
aura des conséquences pour nous mais là
aussi moi je soutiens la position de ba
candidate anne hidalgo qui consiste à
dire il faut aller jusqu'au bout ce sera
des sacrifices pour nous manifestement
la solution ne peut pas être que
national elle doit être négocié au
niveau européen
moi j'ai senti une évolution plus qu'une
évolution un saut dans la solidarité
européenne depuis cette crise tant mieux
l'europe finalement est en train de se
retrouver de se refonder fasse un
événement extérieur dramatique donc il
faudra négocier quels que soient le les
présidents
il fit ou là olaf scholz a pris des
positions très fortes en la matière
l'allemagne plus étonnante que nous des
de l'énergie russe
sûrement sûrement sûrement et personne
aujourd'hui me dis qu'il faut réduire le
nucléaire en france la question de
savoir s'il faut les inventer oui enfin
en tout cas aller les gens responsables
nous peuvent pas dire qu'il faut réguler
nucléaire en france
oui mais dit ne dis pas que ça comme
choses décalées permettez moi
l'expression je n'ai pas oublié sa
dernière sortie puisqu'on parle de
guerre sur la présence en france de la
france au mali et le fait que c'est une
démarche quasiment colonialiste de la
france alors bon voilà c'est monsieur
mélenchon dans ses extrémités verbal
après le reste c'est un autre débat pour
rester au niveau domestique le plan de
résilience à dubaï proposée par le
gouvernement est ce que c'est la bonne
méthode ce qu'il est bon oui enfin il
est bon toujours aux mêmes les efforts
sont pas suffisamment répartie mais le
gouvernement avec la crise de l'aco vide
le quoi qu'il en coûte ce plan de
résilience le gouvernement
gouverne donc si tu prends des décisions
d'isly est ce qu'il fait bien les choses
ce que moi j'estime
qu'ils devraient être prises en
considération et d'ailleurs on l'a vu
aussi dans le plan gouvernemental
proposées par monsieur macron dans le
cadre de son projet politique
c'est que les efforts sont toujours
demandés aux mêmes et que à aucun moment
aucun moment la question fondamentale
qui est celle de la solidarité entre les
français au travers d'un effort demandé
aux aux plus aisés nez ne vient sur la
table le mot pouvoir d'achat n'a pas été
utilisé une seule fois dans la
conférence de presse de 4h30 d'emmanuel
macron pas une seule fois cette
expression n'a été utilisé et en creux
vous regarderez bien aucune aucun effort
supplémentaire n'est demandée à celles
et ceux qui ont le plus bénéficié du
quinquennat précédent donc il est dans
sa logique et le plan de résilience
colle parfaitement au sima
travaillerait un nouveau dispositif qui
serait plus ciblée encore cette fois-ci
qui serait plus ciblée sur les rouleurs
les les gros rouleurs mais qui roule
pour des raisons professionnelles et sur
ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens est ce que
ça vous paraît il je suis pour tout ce
qui te permet une solidarité fléché
donc oui mais ç'aurait pu être déjà le
cas aujourd'hui en tout cas il est une
mesure qui était simple claire juge pour
tout le monde c'est la baisse de la tva
il se refuse à baisser la tva à 5,5
pendant trois quatre cinq mois le temps
de la crise voire plus malheureusement
si elle devait perdurer donc cette
mesure-là été écartée définitivement
écarté je le regrette parce que monsieur
macro est devenu finalement avec
monsieur castex le champion du monde
olympique ou chambre du monde
les deux d'ailleurs
toutes catégories de la prime
la prime énergie la prime essence la
prime alimentation qui est annoncée dans
le programme la prime inflation
il faut arrêter la prime macron imprime
à craon kyi et l'instauration du travail
au noir dans le pays ou disons le
clairement non ça vous avez l'air de
vous étonner ce que
quand vous avez quand vous
écoutez quand vous recevez de l'argent
qui n'est pas fiscalisée qui n'est pas
socialisée qui n'est pas chargée au
niveau de l'employeur c'est de l'argent
celle du black vous et moi c'est bien
c'est de l'argent liquide ils seraient
payés en liquide ce serait exactement la
même chose le même effet et il annonce
sont triplement le triplement de la
prime macron donc toutes ces primes pour
moi sont un non sens sur le plan
économique la vraie question c'est
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat depuis
des salaires du smic et l'ouverture
d'une grande conférence
interprofessionnel sur les salaires dans
notre plan vous voulez
bien évidemment est ce que ça sera comme
jean luc mélenchon un décret à peine élu
25 avril des crédits du smic tout à fait
puisque c'est une horde responsabilité
réglementaire donc le gouvernement peut
décider à condition bien sûr qu'ils
ouvrent derrière cette conférence
interprofessionnelle pour que l'ensemble
des salaires
tout à fait là oui tout à fait et
une hausse aussi potentiel et non pas
annoncée
du point des fonctionnaires je vous
rappelle que les fonctionnaires n'ont
pas eu leur point de manière généralisée
augmenté depuis février 2017 j'étais
encore membre du gouvernement à l'époque
il y avait eu de hausse d'ailleurs une
hausse en octobre 2016 innocents de
fermiers 2017 depuis les fonctionnaires
qui n'ont pas évolué dans leur carrière
ont perdu 8 10 12 % de pouvoir d'achat
parce que l'inflation est repartie donc
il faut que ce gouvernement
comprenne aujourd'hui et peut-être
demain je ne souhaite pas mais peut-être
demain que le pouvoir d'achat est la
priorité absolue des français comment
comment comment comment l'accompagner
les très petites entreprises et les pme
sur une hausse ou si soudaine
vous avez raison de dire que il y a une
différence entre les grandes entreprises
qui vont distribuer 25 ou 30 milliards
d'euros de dividendes cette année et les
petites structures et qui devront être
accompagnés mais finalement le quoi
qu'il en coûte
il a fonctionné
soyons assez intelligent pour peut-être
faire cette différenciation entre le
slow l'entrepreneur qui a trois ou
quatre salariés et celui qui en a dix
mille c'est ça aussi la subsidiarité
c'est à dire ne pas avoir une
application systématique d'où cette
conférence interprofessionnelle on va
parler de la campagne présidentielle
je mets d'abord une proposition
ministère de l'art migration pour jeu le
site renvoyait tous les gens dont on ne
veut plus c'est à dire les clandestins
les richesses et les délinquants qu'est
ce qu'on pensait de sa seat l'horreur
absolue c'est le néo fasciste zemmour
et non pas en action heureusement il ne
le sera pas et heureusement aussi si on
le décide mais il va jusqu'au bout il va
jusqu'au bout de sa logique une logique
qui peut paraître plus douces entre
guillemets que celle de marine le pen un
plus douces ou dures pardon que c'est le
madame le pen même le pen étant plus
douce plus molle dit certains
mais finalement c'est comme l'extrême
droite et la droite extrême qui se
retrouvent et moi ce qui m'inquiète
finalement ces quinzièmes aurait pu
prospérer malgré tout même s'il ya
aujourd'hui à 10 11 12 % il a pu
prospérer
et ça signifie quoi ça signifie que
notre pays aujourd'hui est prêt à donner
environ un tiers de ses voix nos
concitoyens un tiers de leurs voix à
l'extrême droite en france je vous
rappellerai la phrase de monsieur rivaux
c'était je crois au début mai 2010 est
où il avait dit dans une grande chaîne
de radio jeux de mémoire il avait dit
mais il faudra tout faire pour que ce
septennat a abouti à ce que ce
quinquennat ou chantilly ce matin ce
quinquennat
aboutissent à ce qu'il n'y ait pas un
deuxième tour entre un candidat
républicain et l'extrême droite on y va
tout droit vous pensez qu'on y va tout
droit je le crains ce que les français
ne voulaient pas ou disent qu'il ne
voulait jouer à grasse et ça je le
trafic finale moi je souhaite que comac
voilà puisqu'il ya un sursaut dans les
trois dernières semaines de campagne
mais aujourd'hui les sondages si j'en
crois les sondages mais il faut se
méfier des sondages on l'a bien vu aux
élections régionales les sondages à qui
ça cela ce qui signifie que l'engagement
fondamental de monsieur macro qui a
priori sera au second tour je mange pas
vous dire que non il n'y sera pas il n'y
sera pas il sera pas je pense que
j'aurais du mal à me croire il fera au
second tour il a toutes ses chances se
retrouver face encore une fois à
l'extrême droite eh bien ça signifie que
quelque part il devra aussi se poser la
question mais pourquoi on en est arrivé
là il n'y a pas que la copie il ya
évidemment fin je suis dire je mets ma
main n'a jamais tremblé ni en 2002 ni au
moment de l'élection régionale par
rapport à xavier bertrand face à mme le
pen donc il est clair que j'appellerai à
voter maniema comment vous entendez et
comment vous interprétez la petite
musique qui se développe autour de la
question de la légitimité du futur
président ou la future présidente quel
que soit son nom car je suis ou celle
qui sera élue je ne nie pas c'est un
mauvais procès je n'y participe à une
élection eh oui je vais je suis un peu
étonné
je connais la sagesse du président
larcher je suis un peu étonné parce que
non
ça pourrait
prospérer si monsieur macron décidé en
cas de réélection annoncée est toujours
dans les sondages s'il décidé de
dissoudre pour des raisons d'opportunité
gagné quinze jours ou trois semaines par
rapport à l'échéance normale du 12 au 19
juin prochain de l'élection initiative
alors là là vous pensez qu'elle existe
vraiment cette tentation puisque c'est
une espèce de vieille rumeur qui
courrait ya six mois qui a été démenti
qui revient par la bande donc une rumeur
mais il va le faire oui aux castrais son
intérêt je ne discute pas je discutais
qu'une seule fois en tête à tête avec
monsieur maquereau en cinq ans je le
regrette d'ailleurs j'aurais aimé
potentialisation nous pas faire ça ah
mais moi je pense qu'il faut les règles
sont établies on ne change pas les
règles en cours de jeu monsieur macron
s'il devait être réélu ce le sera avec
beaucoup d'abstention chacun le sait
bien et que donc si on ne veut pas que
cette légitimité de l'élection et
qu'enfin kadri à 24 avril soit écornée
il ne faudrait pas toucher aux dates des
élections législatives je lui
déconseille fortement parce qu'alors la
alors là le procès interviendrait et il
serait plutôt juste vous serez en lien
avec la présence de françois
françois hollande fait partie de notre
présent il fait partie aussi de notre
histoire
il fera partie de notre avenir j'en suis
intimement convaincu et je considère que
cette présence après une petite phrase
les analyses les articles dans les
grands journaux lui choir elle est très
importante elle est même indispensable
nous sommes à trois semaines de
l'élection que l'ancien président de la
république vienne soutenir la candidate
socialiste alors qu'il ya elle vous
l'avez vu des reniements des renégats
qui se baladent dans nos rangs je le
regrette que vous comprenez est ce que
vous comprenez il ya bertrand delanoë
qui ne comprend rien du tout ce sont je
sens amène qui est votre prédécesseur
la présidence du groupe il dit moi je
soutiens manuel mâcon mais je reste
socialiste c'est possible ça pour vous
non c'est pas possible il ya quand on
est socialiste on ne soutient pas la
retraite à 65 ans quand on est
socialiste on ne soutient pas la
disparition de la redevance tv pour le
service public quand on est socialiste
on ne soutient pas la conditionnalité
pour obtenir le rsa autant de gens de
droite
tota qui ont une très bien mme pécresse
d'ailleurs elle le dit j'ai été plagiée
donc non ils vont avoir du mal quand
monsieur rebsamen va se retrouver dans l
âme dans la même salle à la même table
avec monsieur eric woerth je souhaite
bien du courage et bien écoutez françois
hollande il a le mérite d'être
socialiste de le rester il a été premier
secrétaire et quand on est socialiste on
soutient la candidate du parti
socialiste
point barre et donc il sera là ce soir
ça va donner du baume au coeur voilà
notre famille politique et anne hidalgo
se place au centre du jeu en disant mais
moi j'ai besoin de celles et ceux qui
ont gouverné dans ce pays
cazeneuve françois hollande martine
aubry aussi mais j'ai aussi le soutien
des nouvelles générations notamment
cette équipe de france des mers et donc
on peut revenir très longtemps en
arrière si vous me demandiez est-ce
qu'il a bien fait de faire sa
déclaration le 1er décembre 2016 pour
dit je ne serai pas candidat ma réponse
est claire je pense qu'il aurait dû être
candidat voilà et j'étais membre de son
gouvernement j'ai été solidaire de sa
décision mais je pense que l'histoire on
aurait été échangé si l'âme était
candidat mais personne ne peut le savoir
en tant que tel on l'a bien compris que
son engagement ce soir à limoges au côté
d'un candidat très important mais est ce
que c'est votre arme secrète de la
dernière chance qui va faire basculer
l'élection ou alors est ce qu'il est en
train de préparer la suite et la suite
c'est quoi pour le ps
là aussi si je vous disais que en trois
semaines nous allons redresser la barre
ça veut dire que remontent les sondeurs
aurait mal fait leur travail
ya cinq ans les 6 % benoît hamon c'était
une catastrophe pour le ps aujourd'hui
je sais un espoir pour vous l'aviez déjà
longtemps que les 6% benoît hamon
s'était notamment été le candidat ps
mais aussi de élevé des radicaux de
gauche et du mrc donc il représentait
quatre formations peuvent rien quand
même un enjeu si votre candidate fait
moins de 5% comment vous faites avec le
l'emprunt sur la campagne alors
le ratio tout d'abord on a emprunté que
huit cent mille euros c'est à dire la
somme qui ne sera quoiqu'il arrive
remboursés par l'état tout le reste est
autofinancé par le ps et les fédérations
et les on a un enjeu non donc si vous
savez on n'a pas dépensé énormément vous
l'avez compris on est plus haut à 15 16
millions d'euros de dépenses les verts
ont plus de soucis d'ailleurs à se faire
parce qu'ils ont fait un emprunt
important pour eux donc donc nous on n'a
pas de problème mais évidemment cette
barre symbolique qui n'est pas que
financière dessin pour cent
on va essayer de détendre aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 2 3% on craignait pas
l'atteindre il faut se battre il faut se
battre les trois semaines qui viennent
et moi je suis convaincu qu au dernier
moment nous aurons un bon résultat en
tout cas un meilleur résultat parce que
j'en appelle et à votre micro aux
électeurs socialistes qui ont voté
hollande en 2012 qui ont voté maquereau
en 2017 parce que la candidature de
benoît hamon ne leur convenait pas qui
aujourd'hui peut être s'apprêtent à
voter mais je le redis ouvrez les yeux
fait tomber les ailières
macro est un président qui a été de
droite et qui le sera encore plus qu'il
sera encore plus la fois prochaine s'il
était réélu donc puisque manifestement
il semble être réélu revenez revenez sur
vos fondamentaux et soutenez la seule
candidate qui est socialiste donc de
gauche g13 et du week-end européenne via
un troisième tour pour c'est pour vous
aux législatives c'est encore pire à
équilibrer je pense qu'ils ont un
équilibrage y compris d'ailleurs dans la
majorité présidentielle
un mauvais score un mauvais score de
votre candidate est ce que vous n'êtes
pas en position de faiblesse après si
vous me faites dire je voulais me faire
dire que il vaut mieux avoir xo % plutôt
que - y compris à gauche
mais la négociation elle sera envisagée
envisageable avec notamment ceux avec
qui nous gouvernent ont déjà pu nous
allons gouverner avec lui au niveau
national nous gouvernons avec au niveau
local je pense en particulier aux pc et
aux verts il faut ouvrir la négociation
et
je sais pas quand on fait ça je ne sais
pas parce qu'il faudra bien regarder le
rapport de force niveau national mais
aussi le rapport de force dans chacune
des 577 circonscriptions
donc c'est un travail de quasiment
chirurgicale un travail de dentelle
qu'il faudra mener mais on aura très peu
de temps et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs et
j'y reviens la position d'une éventuelle
dissolution
ce serait vraiment un par rapport à
l'opposition ce serait un acte si
monsieur macro intérêts lutte est ce
qu'un risque de disparition totale du
parti socialiste d'effondrement non non
vous savez le ps et 100 parlementaires
c'est 25% des villes de plus de 5000
habitants c'est cinq régions il faudrait
y rajouter la martinique où nous avons
ces rejets chimiques est proche de nous
ce sont trente départements donc non
nous l'avons toujours été mais mais mais
il faudra combler le risque d'une
logique groupusculaire facile ça si un
risque pour la formation politique à
laquelle j'appartiens et ça il ya un
travail de reconstruction qui te devrait
être menée le plus vite possible
[Musique]